the following trailer is rated s for
spoilers from the director who exploded
onto the scene then went out like a hot
fart comes what might be and night
Shyamalan's greatest surprise yet he's
actually kind of good again I did not
see this happening what no split James
McAvoy stars as a man with 24 split
personalities in the same body but get
ready to see only about eight of them a
few which kind of blend together I think
I'm talking again still he'll teach a
master class and channeling a wide
variety of creepy personalities like
creepy child someone's coming for you
creepy Tim Gunn that one I'm gonna hand
print it with newspaper headline and
creepy mrs. Doubtfire I think a tricky
flaw and you have as they do a wonderful
job explaining how so many personalities
can coexist in his mind but ignore one
big question how does he always have the
right clothes nearby when he changes
does he keep a grandma sweater in every
room just in case no watch McEvoy act
circles around the rest of the cast
literal circles because his dumbass
victims just stand around and wait to be
eaten or lock themselves into lockers or
not run away when this happens okay and
run run and go run away right now run
you [ __ ] but don't worry
fans of the old batch on Milan because
he'll still be guilty of his trademarks
like vacant scary wood and acting how do
you think and the worst dialog this side
of the happening Jay what
health-conscious fast-food purveyor did
you originally solicit to buy these
chicken wings you so lovingly reheated
in a minor suicidal gesture yep
there's the end that we all know and
hate so prepare for the dawn of a new
Shamala songs
a film that doesn't just kick ass as a
standalone movie it also works as a hold
on if you don't want to twist ending the
split ruined you're going to want to
clear out for this part it's okay I'll
give you some time to click away while
we watch the wind from the happening
okay everyone gone who doesn't want the
big twist boiled alright here goes
it's a secret sequel to unbreakable how
cool is that a movie that seventeen
years old made by a different studio
which most people in the audience likely
forgot about there's no way you saw that
coming now I can't help wondering is it
all connected
who else could show up in the Shambhala
verse could we get a whole the Shamal
Avengers with a kid who sees dead people
hang and cypher Raige and everyone that
would be terrible you're not on the
doghouse yet night man starring the om
night cameo personalities 9 through 23
mister Plunkett's basement beasts mode
activated and what it's like to be a
girl on the Internet
take off your skirt take off your shirt
thank you can I kiss you 10 Cloverfield
room I do have the ability to use
Kevin's full name and bring him forward
this guy is going to be much of a
challenge to Bruce Willis he's got the
same weakness as Rumpelstiltskin thanks
for watching
for even more honest trailers including
rogue one a Star Wars story and the bad
in night Shyamalan movies click the
boxes above be careful not to choke on
your observations I only know one true
it's time for the Jedi to add frankly my
dear I don't give a damn I am the Senate
red lorry yellow lorry red lorry yellow
lorry red lorry yellow lorry red lorry
yellow lorry red lorry yellow lorry red
lorry yellow lorry